digamos que hay cuatro personas en un
cuarto y ya sé que tengo que dejar de
llamarles a las personas con una sola
letra pero ni modo voy a volver a
hacerlo entonces tenemos a cuatro
personas en un cuarto la persona a la
persona ve la persona se y la persona ve
pero estas personas no se conocen
entonces alguien llega y les dice que
quiere que todos se conozcan y que la
mejor forma de hacer eso es ayudarse
estrechando la mano derecha entonces
todas estas cuatro personas se van a
estrechar la mano una sola vez con cada
una de las otras personas en ese cuarto
y mi pregunta para ti es si cada una de
estas cuatro personas se saluda de mano
con las otras tres personas del cuarto
cuántos saludos de mano en total van a
suceder en este cuarto así es que como
siempre por la pausa el vídeo y trata de
encontrar la respuesta bueno voy a
suponer que ya lo intentaste
una forma de pensar en esto es decir ok
para que haya un saludo de menos
necesitamos a dos personas dos personas
porque este saludo no es un saludo de
esos movernos de cuatro personas ok tal
cual una persona saluda con la mano
derecha a otra persona entonces por aquí
cada una de estas cuatro personas va a
tener que saludar a otras personas
entonces aquí tenemos cuatro opciones y
si no tomamos en cuenta esos saludos
extraños que uno podría llegar a tener
con uno mismo entonces aquí tenemos tres
personas con las que se puede saludar
esta otra persona de aquí entonces en
total tenemos cuatro por tres saludos
que son 12 saludos en total acá tenemos
12 posibles saludos lo que quiero que
hagas en este momento es que le pongas
pausa el vídeo otra vez y pienses en si
realmente vamos a tener 12 saludos si
observas esto de aquí lo que tenemos
las permutaciones de cuatro personas en
dos espacios podríamos decir que este es
el espacio de la persona que saluda uno
y que este es el espacio de la persona
que saluda dos y aquí cuando hacemos
cuatro por tres en realidad estamos
haciendo que el orden en el que
acomodamos a las personas en estos dos
lugares importe que aquí estamos
diciendo que el hecho de que la persona
se salude con la persona ve es un evento
y que un evento completamente distinto
que lo estamos contando como otra cosa
en esta cuenta es que la persona ve
salud a la persona
pero eso no es lo que queremos nosotros
queremos que estas dos cosas cuenten
como una sola cosa lo que hay que no
importa si la está a la izquierda y la
ve a la derecha que esto es lo mismo que
si las cambiamos del lugar ok no
queremos que sí
estaba viendo hacia el norte cuando se
saludó con ver entonces se tengan que
volver a saludar pero
ahora con ve viendo hacia el norte
queremos que estas dos permutaciones
cuenten como una sola cosa entonces por
aquí en este cuatro por tres igualdad 12
estamos contando todos los saludos dos
veces así es que lo que realmente
queremos son las combinaciones de estas
cuatro personas
en dos de cuantas formas podemos escoger
a dos personas entre estas cuatro
personas
ok cuantas
cuántas formas
ay
de escoger
escoger a dos personas 2
zonas porque eso es lo que realmente
estamos haciendo en cada saludo se
escogen a dos personas así es que lo que
queremos saber es de cuántas formas
podemos escoger a dos de estas cuatro
personas y no nos importa el orden en el
que las escogemos queremos que cada
saludo tenga una combinación diferente
de personas por aquí en estos dos
tenemos exactamente la misma combinación
de personas entonces esto no es lo que
estamos buscando lo que nosotros
necesitamos ahorita es ver cuáles son
las combinaciones de cuatro en dos esto
es lo mismo que preguntarnos cuántas son
las combinaciones de cuatro personas en
dos que también es lo mismo que decir
que de cuatro personas vamos a escoger
dos y para sacar esta cantidad lo que
hacemos es fijarnos en las permutaciones
por aquí ya vimos que las permutaciones
son 4 x 3
entonces ponemos por aquí 4 x
es permutaciones y dividimos entre la
cantidad de formas que tenemos de
ordenar a dos personas y esas son dos
porque una persona puede estar del lado
izquierdo y la otra del lado derecho o
pueden estar al revés esa persona puede
estar a la derecha y la otra persona a
la izquierda entonces por aquí tenemos
que dividir entre dos que además es
exactamente igual a dos factorial porque
dos factoriales dos por uno que es
simplemente dos ok esto de aquí
es el número de formas de formas de
ordenar orden
a dos personas
personas y esto de aquí que estoy aquí
es el número de permutaciones
pero no está
acción es la cantidad de formas de
escoger a dos de estas cuatro personas y
ordenarlas
el orden es muy importante en las
permutaciones entonces este 2 que
tenemos por aquí podríamos pensar que
está corrigiendo eso de que las
permutaciones tomen en cuenta el orden
está corrigiendo el hecho de que aquí
para cada par de personas estamos
contando dos saludos y por supuesto
puedes simplemente aplicar la fórmula
pero aquí ya lo razonamos ok por aquí
teníamos cuatro por tres pero estábamos
contando dos veces cada saludo entonces
para corregirlo simplemente tenemos que
dividir entre dos y nos queda 6
y podemos pensarlo así y aquí nos queda
6 o podemos simplemente aplicar la
fórmula aunque hay de 4 personas
queremos escoger 2 estamos buscando
cuántas combinaciones de cuatro personas
en dos hay aunque hay de cuatro escoges
dos y la fórmula lo que nos dice es que
tenemos cuatro factorial entre dos
factorial por cuatro menos dos factorial
cuatro menos dos factorial a ver vamos a
poner a la cantidad de personas que se
saluden de rosa y entonces lo que nos
queda aquí arriba 4 por 3 por 2 por 1 y
luego este 2 factorial es un 2 por 1 y
finalmente este 4 - 2 factorial es un 2
factorial que es un 2 por 1 y entonces
este 2 por 1 se cancela con este 2 por 1
este 1 no nos aporta nada
este 2 divide a este 4 y entonces nos
quedan dos por 3 y 2 por 3 6
y para que quede todavía más claro ahora
lo que vamos a hacer es dibujar todos
los saludos
ok tenemos que podría saludar a b o
podría saludar a c y podría saludar a d
y luego tenemos que ver podría saludar
bueno a ver lo primero que vamos a hacer
es pensar en los saludos de esta forma
cuando nos salieron 12 saludos y después
vamos a ver cómo en realidad son
únicamente 6 saludos porque hay entonces
ve también puede saludar a y b puede
saludar a c y b puede saludar a b y se
puede saludar a y se convi y se conde y
luego de con a y b con b y b con c y
aquí tenemos 12 saludos
tenemos las 12 permutaciones si para
nosotros se de fuera distinto que desee
entonces esta sería la cantidad total de
saludos pero no a nosotros no
a quién va primero y tema después lo
único que nos importa es quiénes están
saludando entonces al saludo entre las
personas se ve sin importar el orden lo
estamos contando dos veces y lo mismo
pasa con el resto de los saludos los
estamos contando dos veces porque hay
porque el saludo ave es exactamente el
mismo saludo que el saludo ve a y hace
es el mismo saludo que se ha y ade es lo
mismo que ve a ibc es lo mismo que se ve
y verde es lo mismo que bebe y cede es
lo mismo que desee entonces si
corregimos eso de que los saludos los
estamos contando dos veces nos quedan 1
2 3
456 saludos 6 combinaciones de dos
personas que jugando de cuatro personas
tenemos que escoger dos personas y no
nos importa el orden en el que las
escogemos obtenemos seis saludos hay
seis posibles formas de escoger a dos
personas de un grupo de cuatro personas